à lausanne à
johanna nous accueille chez elle à
chilliwack elle vient tout juste de
rentrer à la maison six jours après
avoir été évacuée
cette soirée les unités vendues
ma maison est non elle constate qu'elle
a été épargnée comme la plupart des
habitations dans son quartier d'ailleurs
tous ici sont soulagés
des amis
à quelques pas de chez johanna le niveau
de l'eau a commencé à diminuer mais vous
le constatez autour de nous pas assez
pour permettre à tous ceux qui le
souhaitent de rentrer chez eux les
terres agricoles ici ressemble davantage
à un lac et la route sur laquelle on se
trouve est toujours impraticable
l'eau recouvre la chaussée ces fermes
sont toujours inaccessibles
le retour à la normale n'est pas pour
bientôt
ce producteur laitier dont le terrain
est surélevée à héberger des vaches de
fermes avoisinantes pour les sauver il
ne sait pas pendant combien de temps
elles resteront ici
des milliers d'animaux sont morts dans
cette région agricole un drame pour
plusieurs éleveurs
maintenant il faut réparer ce que l'on
peut réparer de nombreuses routes comme
celles ci ont été morcelées par les
glissements de terrain
dubois c'est juste une maison c'est
juste des choses - la ram est en
sécurité dans leur ensemble
pratiquant c'est ce que se répète
toujours ceux qui ne peuvent qu'attendre
en espérant que la pluie ne vienne pas
tout gâcher